what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch today
from Ryan Jorge the pitch meeting for
Avatar dos the way of Aqua John how are
you I am a Cameron girl in a Cameron
world how are you sir good job
leave a like we would really appreciate
that leave a like thank you to all who
join us in the live stream we just
wrapped up doing and people mentioned
this I was like yeah we gotta watch this
subscribe to pitch meeting if you
haven't done so already let's see what's
going on
so you have a movie for me yes sir it's
about time for another Avatar movie oh
yeah bring those blue kitty cats back in
here I can't wait to see what's going on
with uh
main character
I know that's the thing that I knew for
more than one week in December 2009.
well Jake Sully's back sir and we're
heading back to that planet everybody
knows and loves which is called the door
I said it at the same time as you as
because of how much I love and remember
great
on this one like I want to set a world
record on this bad boy oh I like the
sound of that highest grossing movie of
all time yeah maybe so what movie with
the most frequent use of the word bro
yeah they're gonna throw a crazy number
of times
is that gonna get annoying maybe you
think it won't bro because that's how
kids talk these days bro it's relatable
did you just say bro latable I will say
you know the one thing I was the most
forgiven about with the movie was
dialogue because I was like oh whatever
that was my attitude the whole time with
it was like ah whatever I didn't expect
the dialogue itself to be great that was
distracting because it just had me going
like Jake must have taught that right
was Jake showing them movies
but Jake's would be like yeah he called
him bro it's your bro Jake must have
taught the lingo right because they're
mainly hanging out with other knobby
people they're not really hanging out
with like modern day American kids they
were like what's up dude what's up bro
what's up guys or inversely they're not
hanging out with like Samoans or
Hawaiians or any like indigenous uh you
know people to those regions that they
will be hanging out with later in the
movies so you could argue like you know
like the reef people being like yeah bro
like maybe tangentially it makes sense
but yeah like for some reason uh the
only thing that really uh tracks is the
whole server thing anyway we're back on
Pandora and it's been like 10 years
since the events of the first movie and
Jake has a bunch of kids they're getting
busy with their tails or whatever is
tight yeah so they did whatever that was
and now they have in the table talking
Gary was that one name no that's four
names fascinating and so Carrie's like
this teenager that was mysteriously born
from Grace Augustine's Avatar you know
Sigourney Weaver's character from the
first movie oh who are we gonna get to
play this teenager I got just the person
Sigourney Weaver you think it's gonna be
kind of weird to hear Senior Citizens
Voice coming out of a kid oh yeah maybe
for me I didn't even I don't notice
until the second anyway so another kid
they're raising is this human kid spider
what's his deal he's actually the son of
quarrich you know the main bad guy from
the first movie oh and so who's going to
be the main bad guy in this movie Quarry
do you know the main bad guy no wait no
wait no he died in the first movie I'm
pretty sure whoops nope not a whoopsie
you're not getting a whoopsie out of me
no whoopsie no whoopsie Cersei the thing
is humans are actually back on Pandora
now and Jake is leading the resistance
against them okay and turns out the
humans had a backup of quarry's mind and
memory so they shoved that into an
avatar body wow well I guess they really
wanted the expertise of you know a guy
who did not succeed last time
resources into bringing back the best
guy for the job the guy who failed
spectacularly last time and literally
died it's not a bad thing it's not a bad
plan that is such a solid Point even
though I know it's made for joking
references here but I never even
considered that like the dude totally
failed you'd think they would probably
want to bring in a new person and you
could do the job and Philip like no he's
the one he knows them but I'm like he
doesn't really know a big part of the
movie is him learning how all this works
and everything he doesn't really
understand the culture how [ __ ] really
goes down yeah he's not actually the
best person for the job you would think
that within the 10 years it's been plus
since the last movie they would have
another expert on Pandora somewhere in
the organization you might as well just
made him he had a twin brother too yeah
why not hey you know it's just as
believable so anyway Quarry rich in his
Squad pretty much immediately run into
Jake's kids so Jake and natiri need to
go say well that little Squad doesn't
stand a chance against Jake and his
whole tribe oh no Jake and Nate Dairy
don't bring any back up why not so the
movie can happen oh okay so courage ends
up kidnapping his son spider and Jake's
like well I guess I gotta resign this
head of the resistance and move away
with my family why well if they stick
around they'd be putting everybody in
danger you know they can't win a fight
against korich they literally did that
in the last time they move away and go
live with this water Clan that's all
about water oh water is different from
forests and for the next long stretch of
the movie it's gonna be kind of like a
nature documentary with some teenage
angst sprinkled in now what's Jake gonna
be up to oh you're gonna like this he's
gonna lecture his kids a couple times I
do like watching disciplinary lectures
everybody does and So eventually Jake's
son Loach becomes friends with a big old
space whale a big old space whale a big
old space whale out and then also Carrie
has you know I I've heard quite a few
people say that they felt like the whale
part of the movie that whale
specifically was not essential and felt
like it was just out of a Disney movie
or something but what was one of my
absolute favorite parts of the movie
yeah I when he shows up that whale back
at the end it is getting his revenge I'm
like hell yeah
so catharsis that's such a cathartic
moment I mean I love the hell out of it
I thought it was amazing and the way
they realized their perspective like I
never really quite seen something like
that before in a movie like this yeah
and it also goes to show you that yes
whales are very even though it's a
different kind of well I don't know
people too whales are very smart they're
very intelligent creatures and then also
Carrie has super powers now she can like
communicate with creatures and whatnot
well good for her yeah so she's having a
great time pretty much of the whole
movie while people are arguing or
fighting she's just looking around like
oh
okay oh wow nice but eventually we're
gonna figure out where Jake is so
they're going to keep on going with
their mission of trying to kill him I
mean Jake's gone and he's not the leader
of the resistance anymore why is their
top priority still trying to take him
out well because see that's the plot of
the movie that works
that's so funny because when we were
watching the movie I I did lean over to
John going
is there something more to Jake that
they really need because they really
seem like they're backing his revenge
Quest against Jake so much or I'm like
they don't really need him than someone
else who works at Looper
who came in and it was like well I think
it's because they think he might like he
would know their their tactics and stuff
because he was part of the military so
they have to take him out I'm like but
that doesn't really come into play in
the film the movie pretty much it gives
you that one line where they're like
yeah Jake's leading the resistance and
and every time we try to attack he's
always got them just so organized that
they beat us in like 10 minutes he's
gone and yeah so we're fine yeah yeah
yeah like the military is so gung-ho for
I don't know I was on board for it
because I I like the villain a lot you
know always unconfident on how to
pronounce his name
so quoridge teams up with these people
who actually hunt those big old space
whales and they want to kill some of
them to lure Jake out why do those guys
hunt big old space whales because
they're freaking brain juice stops
people from aging so what happened to
that stuff the humans were after in the
first one titanium yeah they were unable
to obtain it that makes a lot of sense
actually yeah that checks out but the
thing about these big old space whales
is that they're very hard to kill and
how they find out about the magical
brain juice in the first place I don't
know well okay then so then Jake and
there's some people they tried really
hard this is gonna be a big old fight oh
boy here we go and a big old space
whale's gonna help them out and it's
going to be crazy and then Tatum is
going to die oh no yeah and so the Sully
family are very sad but quartz and a
couple of his guys are still alive well
it's gonna be hard for a couple of bad
guys to stand a chance against all the
ocean people actually it's going to be
super easy barely an inconvenience oh
really yeah I can see it's actually just
gonna be Jake and his family fighting
these dudes now what happened to the
ocean people oh no those guys they all
left they had to go away
yes
you know head out they got they gotta
leave early yeah they dive into the
water under the fire so the big never
even questions
ship that's sinking isn't that kind of
similar to yeah James Cameron
specifically requested that I don't know
what to tell you oh this guy freaking
hates when sea vessels float as intended
just to choke unconscious let him sink
to the bottom wow but then that spider
kid's Gonna Save him what why see equal
he probably just caused a lot Co pain
and suffering for his loved ones equal
you know all right you make a good point
that really frustrated me in the movie
it was such a frustrating moment I get
the movies it has its reasons that you
can you can pick apart as to why he
would do it but the movie does go out of
its way especially corporate blue Corp
rich or Rich quarrett courage God damn
it quidditch goes out of his way to
point out I am not your father yeah I am
just some Avatar with of copy memory in
here yeah it's okay if I go yeah I you
know in fact they could just clone Me
Maybe
you could have 10 dads don't need to
save me yeah like and there was there
was never and I think the thing too is
with spiders he has a very specific
association with what his father was
like and then maybe the movie just
doesn't have it in there there was no
real scenes in there that showed oh
they're becoming a true father and Sun
thing and he's really getting to see
such a different side to him but I'm
like after everything you're done like
he went after your real family yeah and
try really killing them like not this uh
that annoyed me again kisses at him
well yeah yeah I mean it's that sort of
like our debt is paid like you you
didn't kill me so I won't leave you to
die but at the same time there's no dead
paid there's no debt at all here that's
because he didn't kill some spiders well
yeah no it's not cool that's fair
there's no matter there's a lot of
people who already like [ __ ] typing
where you don't get movies
we don't yeah no just me while we're
here just me they're all on your side
John that's right
um so that's about it what do you think
well I mean the first movie made an
insane amount of money so I'm pumped
let's get this out ASAP let's do it what
are you thinking like a 2014 release
date that sounds like a great release
here let's lock it in
[Music]
ah good times good times good times good
times all right Ryan George you knocked
it out of the park yet again killing it
yet again I don't know how you managed
to
write these in under six minutes of
pressure three hours later I could do
this in six minutes very I think that
level of credit is not dished out enough
to Ryan George who can produce a high
quality pitch meeting for some of these
very lengthy films and a quite an
efficient time you know what I mean guys
very impressive stuff all right guys
well subscribe to Ryan George what'd you
think of Avatar the way of water before
we go let's end this with a patreon
Chase Gardner oh I want to thank you for
uh pitching in to our live stream that
we had earlier today pitch you know you
picked out you pitched into our live
stream and then you contribute to our
patreon you're just giving us money all
around what you need to do is just
realize that
you need to write a will where your last
remaining earnings in your life
insurance policy goes to us yeah so
that's only fair yeah I'm willing to
consent to that I know it's a lot of
responsibility on my end but I'm willing
to take all your money if that means you
are a happier person
so Chase all about you chase I
appreciate
um what you're asking of us consider it
our Christmas present to you
that we are willing to take all your
money after death Greg guitar the way of
money thank you Chase for being awesome
I hope you have a Merry Christmas uh but
please don't forget to uh unleash it all
anything where you have Investments made
and stocks your Roth rra savings account
savings bonds funds anywhere make sure
to send it our way happy New Year but
don't forget 2023 you got a big task you
gotta knock out because you never know
when death might come so you gotta you
gotta knock it off faster than you might
expect yeah and if you see a guy show up
at your door after signing this contract
dressed in a black suit loading
something in the shadows like what is
going on there like a barrel uh don't
worry about it just open that door greet
him with a big smile hi how can I help
you I'm a Christian man named Chase
Gardner may the Lord be with you go
through with it trust me it's gonna be a
great read it'll be over in a second
foreign